bonjour fabien gilot mercier a d'être
avec nous ce matin sur arte france vous
êtes donc en italie comment les italiens
qui perçoivent la venue d' emmanuel
macron et que signifie pour eux la
signature de ce pacte du queens
alors il ya plusieurs éléments bien sûr
un boa autour de cela on va dire que
bien sûr aujourd'hui il ya un autre fait
politique très important en italie qui
la réforme fiscale donc beaucoup
d'italiens aujourd'hui ont les yeux
rivés plus sur les possibilités d'avoir
les déductions fiscales
mais bien entendu les italiens regardent
cette venue d' emmanuel macron je dirais
que c'est dans la ligne et finalement de
ce que peut être mario draghi jusqu'à
présent il a une très grande confiance
des italiens actuellement c'est une
grande stabilité et donc les italiens
ont plutôt confiance en mario draghi et
sont certains que cet accord devrait
plutôt aller correctement
après des années compliquées entre paris
et rome notamment quand matteo salvini
était ministre de l'intérieur de
l'intérieur est ce qu'on peut parler
d'une nouvelle entente franco italienne
et cette entente est ce qu'elle peut
être moteur au sein de lieux à l'heure
où angela merkel est sur le départ en
allemagne
oui tout à fait je pense qu'il ya
vraiment un avantage il ya vraiment un
intérêt possible pour les deux pays y
avoir un rapprochement encore plus fort
peut-être même potentiellement beaucoup
plus fort que celui qu'il ya entre la
france et l'allemagne aujourd'hui ce
nouveau traité va justement rapporter
encore plus le rapprochement politique
et artistique et culturelle va vraiment
rapproché les deux cultures au maximum
il y a même d'autres idées à la terre de
ce traité bien sûr qu'on va découvrir ce
matin on connais pas trop les grandes
lignes encore la presse italienne
aujourd'hui parler d'un autre article
qui pourraient être ajoutés aujourd'hui
qui indiquerait la présence d'un
ministre français au conseil des
ministres italien tous les trois mois et
inversement ministre italien au conseil
des ministres français tous les trois
mois de manière à voir la plus grande
synergie pour l'éthique en cours oui
franchement il peut y avoir un nouveau
mobilier urbain
donc on a compris il ya des ligne sur
lesquels paris et rome s'entendent mais
quels sont les points de divergence
entre les deux pays
il ya peut-être un point de divergence
sont peut-être une petite angoisse
italienne du peut-être à quelques
affaires dans le passé il ya encore et
la presse italienne parle encore de la
sphère de fincantieri l'entreprise
italienne qui devait racheter les
entreprises de construction de bateaux à
nantes et le bloc 1 de l'état français
qui avait empêché justement cette fusion
il y a un peu cette crainte de certains
entrepreneurs italiens de ne pas pouvoir
toujours y gagner ce qui est sûr bien
sûr c'est qu'il est aussi un
déséquilibre économique entre les deux
pays la france est le deuxième
investisseur en italie alors que
l'italie n'est que le huitième en france
il y a quand même donc cette petite
crainte qui est justement relevé par les
frères d'italie que vous avez des
retards le reportage qui a une petite
crainte que la france puisse imposer un
peu plus par rapport à cet accord
justement les frères d'italie fratelli
d'italia qui évoquent un scandale
puisque
ce texte n'a pas été soumis au parlement
quelles conséquences
justement
les conséquences vont être assez maigre
je pense parce que justement parle d'un
accord très stratégique qui regardent
plutôt la politique internationale
n'aurait pas vraiment sa place à
l'intérieur
du parlement et il ya aussi un autre
aspect c'est que fratelli d'italia les
et sa leader georgia meloni l'oeil est
là vraiment on va dire un aspect quand
ils français on peut le dire la fois
plusieurs vidéos contre la france durant
les dernières années donc finalement le
poursuit dans la lutte qu'elle avait
jusqu'à présent justement avec ses
craintes justement d'une imposition
français sur certains points mais je
pense que l'impact sera très neutre et
dans l'ensemble de cet accord devrait se
c'est très positif pour les deux pays on
sait qu'il y avait là on a parlé en
début de ce jt de la crise migratoire
entre la france et la grande bretagne à
l'époque il y avait des sujets de
tension au niveau de la crise migratoire
aussi entre la france et l'italie
emmanuel macron voit le pape également
aujourd'hui ils vont parler de la
question migratoire qu'est ce qu'on peut
attendre de cette rencontre et comment
se positionne mario draghi vis-à-vis de
cela également
justement je pense que là aussi le
bailleur une bonne opportunité de
pouvoir mieux avoir une meilleure
synergie par exemple entre les polices
j'étais il ya quelques semaines dans le
val d'aoste et en parlant justement avec
les forces de l'ordre italiennes elle
m'expliquait qu'il avait souvent un
problème de synergie du tout simplement
parfois des effets très structurelles
problème d' espaces donc je pense que
justement à voir ce nouvel accord va
permettre de mettre à plat certains
points de mieux collaborer et donc mieux
gérer cette crise migratoire immigration
mois s'est souvent plainte de la france
de l'union européenne quand elle
accueillait des migrants notamment son
île italienne de lampedusa
tout à fait tout à fait peut-être que
l'ajustement on peut espérer qu'il y ait
une meilleure meilleur travail justement
une meilleure collaboration franco
italienne là c'est bien sûr il faut
avoir l'accord ce qu'ils prévoient pour
l'instant bien entendu l'île d'elle en
fait vous avez beaucoup plus loin de la
france que peut être la frontière des
alpes on peut espérer quelque chose mais
là encore on n'a pas encore les éléments
autour de cette de cet aspect là bien
sûr qu'il se sera un des sujets
fondamentaux aussi de cet accord
dernière question si on sait qu'il ya le
dossier du lyon turin
avec souvent des des antagonismes entre
la france et l'italie est ce que ça ça
va être évoquée aussi
c'est une bonne question car c'est
toujours
je travaille également à turin et c'est
toujours un problème puisque la ligne
lyon turin est plutôt voulu par les deux
pays ce n'est pas tant ça le problème
c'est que de la population locale
italienne des flancs la vallée parce que
c'est une vallée qui est aussi une zone
vallée de suse nature c est donc ce sera
très certainement un pont aussi puisque
côté français on va dire que les
chantiers sont très avancées wordpress
côté italien nettement moins due à ses
problèmes politiques je pense que là
aussi malheureux qui pourrait dans ce
cas là qu'on ait une décision peut-être
plus forte et plus immédiate du fait
qu'actuellement il est extrêmement
apprécié merci beaucoup fabien gilot
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes enseignant à
l'université de turin et spécialistes
évidemment de la politique italienne